[Music]
how are you so good to see you good to
see you in real life I know I know not
no longer over Zoom we all get to wear
pants again so you love food but wait
there's still one thing that even you
don't like right there are several
there's several what's something like I
hate brussels sprouts really no matter
how you make them so those bright red
maraschino cherries give me the heebie
JoJo's for real really
really uh green bell pepper so I can tie
the stem oh I love you you know just see
if you're a good kisser like from Junior
High yeah yeah wow I really feel like my
resume is what no my grandma could so it
explains why I have so many aunts and
uncles
seriously well the little makeup my
grandma anymore the cherries and what
else I would say you know those little
chunks of ham like in the Denver
omelette oh like that like cartilaginous
texture I don't like that it's like
rubbery yes yes yes little like grisly
texture that's not polite and green bell
pepper like like royal green bell pepper
I love bell pepper but you know the
thing is it's like an autumn leaf it's
they're the exact same pepper but when
the chlorophyll breaks down like an
autumn leaf they become red and orange
and yellow yeah but when they're green
It's actually an immature pepper and
like in very select cases but usually
it's just not my thing oh my God I love
that's like the one thing I grow in my
garden that I always have oh really well
green yellow red all pepper I love bell
peppers so good well today is all about
grilling I love grilling so did you grow
up with family barbecues and that kind
of stuff I sure did even though I grew
up in Brooklyn my dad made a rest in
peace he would Grill like uh Little Neck
clams and Cherry Stone clams on the
grill on a Weber grill and they would
pop open and just the natural juices and
stuff
um growing up in Brooklyn there were
lots of these Salu Maria these
traditional Italian pork stores so Dad
would get these incredible sausages and
stuff like that it was so good and so
I've got like these great memories of of
grilling and it's so different than when
I moved to the South you learned that
barbecue was a noun and not a verb and
then you're like oh okay what we call
barbecue you call a cookout what you
call barbecue we call pulled pork I got
it yeah God I love some pulled pork
right I know what's wrong with people
proof God loves us and wants us to be
happy and I say that as a general yeah
it is sacrificial
sacrificious the way you did you did an
episode all about the early days of
grilling in America so what did you
learn a ton so I mean the thing is you
have to remember barbecues used to be
like this brick structure that was
immovable so if it rained you couldn't
bring it in couldn't bring it under the
shelter there was no way to clean out
charcoal and the Advent of something
like the Weber grill really was a game
changer and then after World War II when
you had the rise of Suburbia having a
grill was kind of a status symbol so it
was really cool and of course people
forget that Henry Ford was really the
first pioneer of grilling and he gave
out barbecue grills with the purchase of
a new Model T Ford and the thing that's
so crazy is his wife's cousin bought a
Timber Mill because each Model T took
about a hundred board feet of wood they
had all this extra wood he said listen
we have these grills let's make charcoal
and he started this charcoal Factory he
hired Thomas Edison to build a charcoal
Factory and what was his wife's cousin's
last name Kingsford it and that's how
Kingsford Charcoal was born and then
eventually they moved on and we now know
the Weber grill and of course we're
talking Weber well I have it's the best
that's the best it's that beautiful clam
shell it's aesthetically beautiful and
naturally if it's a company called Weber
it was founded by a man named George
Stevens who had 12 kids I used to say he
was like a welder with 12 kids he should
have welded a zipper shot but he can't
yeah right but a lot of cherry stem
tie-in exactly nice nice call back
you're welcome but he had he had seen
them building buoys to Mark channels in
the ocean he said that's how I'm going
to build a grill and suddenly it was
lightweight it was portable you could
spherical that's how it it was it's
always so Random if you look at like
Pringles that cam was inspired by tennis
balls the shape of the Pringle the
hyperbolic paraboloid inspired by a
saddle
um the box for Nerds candy of the year
in 1984 as solidly so so good so good so
good it was made from the leftover bits
of everlasting Gobstoppers that were
left in the machine and those cool boxes
with the sliding doors those were
rejected packages from Winston and
Marlboro cigarettes what yes yes so
remember kids eat candy don't smoke
or like did you remember those candy
cigarettes when you're a kid oh I do in
the bubble gum I used to think I was so
cool but like it's so inappropriate to
have kids walking around me like um all
right like I came again yes I came to a
Jewish costume thing dressed like Don
Johnson from Miami Vice with my with no
socks oh it was very rough you were a
hit yeah Don Johnson wits very sexy and
then I had to blow the little sugar out
of my things and you know people were
like oh it's awful with the kids with
the fake smoking it's terrible
to the eating everybody like I said
today is our summer cookout and we are
going well beyond the basics we are
leveling up our barbecue with some of
the best female chefs in The Culinary
world when it comes to cooking these
women have dominated in a field largely
run by men let's meet them now so first
up she's a James Beard award winner
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I think the last time I saw you we were
doing karaoke together we're off to
doing karaoke together what was the song
Do you remember this one does an amazing
version of the song Wagon Wheel
Darius Rucker
hey baby rock me I'm not let me know the
name oh yeah I know that song The Wind
and the rain and all okay the weather I
did not know it from the title so I just
let myself down
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
guys I'm going home
[Music]